hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure Meinung
und heute packen wir Kartons aus und
nicht irgendwelche Kartons sondern
Festival Gadgets von Amazon ich bin mal
wieder durchs Internet gesurft und habe
mal geschaut was gibt es denn heutzutage
was man so auf ein Festival mitnehmen
kannst ein das Leben erleichtert was
einfach einem eine gute Zeit bereitet
früher hat natürlich ein Zelten Isomatte
unten Gaskocher gereicht aber
mittlerweile leben wir im Konsum
Paradies das Internet macht alles
möglich super und bald noch viel mehr
ich versuche es ich schaffe es bei
keinem Video obwohl es mir einen
finanziellen Vorteil bringt euch die
Sachen unten zu verlinken die ich im
packe so geldgeil bin ich dass ich das
jedesmal wieder vergessen genauso
[Musik]
ich habe Leute schon zur Fusion fahren
sehen ganz schön viele aus Berlin sind
mit Sack und los okay
Rocky talkies hört mir zu
wenn man auf einem Festival ist hat man
oft kein Netz und wenn man mit seiner
besten Freundin sein besten Freund
unterwegs ist senden kann man einfach in
Kontakt bleiben ja ich habe online
gelesen dass es dazu kommen kann dass
man abgehört wird also ihr solltet jetzt
nicht eure Passwörter weitergeben wenn
ihr nur ein kleines Stück seid so wie
ich dann wisst ihr wie toll das ist ein
Walkie Talkie mal in der Hand zu haben
ich habe davon als Kind geträumt und
dann ist es auch noch von Motorola ich
glaube eins meiner ersten Handys Waffen
Motorola wie viel Reichweite vier
Kilometer
[Musik]
hallo hallo hallo hallo bist du da
oh mein Gott ich bin wieder sowas von
fünf hallo
ich hätte das jemanden geben müssen
das waren Gespenst also ich gehe jetzt
mal an ein anderes Zimmer ihr seid jetzt
meine Freundin oder mein Kumpel und wir
haben uns jetzt auf dem Festival
verloren okay
hallo bist du da ich bin ich bin hier
beim fressstand kannst du mich hören ich
bin hier gerade bei ähm imagine Dragons
ist das toll und okay ich bin vielleicht
ein bisschen zu alt dafür aber super
praktisch einfach nur zur Sicherheit
einfach nur zu sagen hey egal was
passiert wir können uns finden
[Applaus]
das
hallo ist da jemand
oh das ist gruselig
[Applaus]
das unfassbar
19,99 leute das ist Geschenk das ist ja
das beste also Spielzeug auch für Kinder
und andererseits habe ich echt ein
bisschen Schiss davor ich habe das
Gefühl ich glaube jetzt ein bisschen
mehr an Geister als vorher aber trotzdem
Zeit des auszumachen und wenn wir schon
mal beim Thema Sicherheit sind Drink
safe sehr wichtig das ist ein Haargummi
Slash schwächerschutz damit jeder
niemand was rein kippt
ah ja okay das ist ein Haargummi und das
ist das für den Becher seht ihr wie ich
durchschaue wahrscheinlich nicht
theoretisch das war einfach rüber und
Strohhalm rein dann kannst du feiern gut
ich denke wenn der Becher voll wäre das
jetzt hier gerade schwer das ist
wirklich sehr spät ist es sehr dunkel
und ich gucke mir dann Konzert an und
steh dann da total hypnotisiert von
Tokio Hotel die gerade auf der Bühne
alles geben und dann kommt jemand von
der Seite und gibt mir da was rein ich
würde das ja niemals mitbekommen ist
nett ich würde glaube ich die ganze Zeit
dieses Haar wieder dabei tragen so es
ist super außer es gibt keine Strohhalme
dann ist natürlich praktisch aber ich
finde man müsste dafür doch gar nicht
geben wo sind denn die ganzen Firmen wo
sind
denn was auch immer packt euer Logo oder
drauf und verteilt diese Dinge im Club
und in Bars und sonst wo habe ich
bezahlt 9,90 € und von mir eine kleine
zehn von zehn
ist das nächste Produkt das ist das
nächste Produkt
Halleluja falls ihr warum die Frau
schwanger ist es gibt die urinella das
ist so das Original Ding das Problem ist
eine wiederverwendbare urinella ist zwar
eine gute Sache aber wenn man auf dem
Festival ist sehr unpraktisch weil ich
möchte ungern mit meinem Pipi Becher
rumlaufen nachdem ich ihn auch benutzt
habe in dem Dixi Globus wirklich nicht
Wasser zum ausspielen oder so okay und
da muss ich leider sagen geht mein
Komfort vor
oh mein Gott ihr wisst gar nicht was das
für mich bedeutet das ist Freiheit
[Musik]
falls ihr euch die ganze Geschichte
nicht vorstellen könnte ich demonstriere
es kurz
[Applaus]
ist das lustig oh mein Gott ich würde
aber nach so ein paar Bier sage ich euch
ganz ehrlich würde ich mich auch an
diese Männer pinkelbetten da hinstellen
und ganz stolz daneben stehen und sagen
jawohl hier bin ich okay probiert gleich
20 Minuten später
des fast so geil
ich bin
kennt ihr diese Filme wo Frauen Mann die
Körper tauschen und dann ist man so wow
so fühlt sich ein Männerkörper an genau
so hat es sich gerade angefühlt ich
stand da ich konnte erstmal nicht
pinkeln weil ich mich nicht überwinden
konnte im Stehen zu pinkeln irgendwann
verpasst es ist eine Erfahrung für sich
muss man wirklich sagen was haben die
gekostet 12,99 €. ich sag zehn von zehn
sehr sehr praktisch die nächste Sache
habe ich auch bestellt um sie auf dem
Festival zu testen ich hatte jetzt aber
schon die Ehre es vorher testen zu
können
ich was dran war eine Probe Essen Slash
Trinken für meine Geburtstagsparty ich
wollte den Laden mal ausprobieren und
gucken ob alles so passt und danach
brauchte ich wirklich
das Problem ist aber mit elotrans
gewesen dass das jetzt in der Partyszene
so beliebt war weil es einfach den Kater
viel kleiner macht als er eigentlich ist
und die Symptome nicht nur bekämpft
sondern auch so ein bisschen die Ursache
dass das in Apotheken ausverkauft war
was natürlich nicht nur blöd ist für die
Leute die wirklich krank sind sondern
dann auch ein bisschen und also es ist
einfach unfair man kauft es zum Party
saufen feiern und andere Leute sind
krank und bräuchten das also ich habe
schon gar nicht mehr gekauft weil ich
einfach mal so ein super schlechtes
Gewissen bekommen habe wenn ich es
gekauft habe aber jetzt haben sie
elotrans reload rausgebracht hier steht
nichts mehr von Durchfallerkrankungen
sondern
enthält ausgesucht Inhaltsstoffe die den
Körper nach anstrengenden Aktivitäten
oder bei Erschöpfung unterstützen kann
was Sie damit sagen wollen aber nicht
offiziell sagen dürfen Kater trinken
jetzt bitte das
das schmeckt für mich wirklich einfach
nur nach einer salzigen Mischung aber es
ist auch vollkommen in Ordnung ich meine
Trinkbecher und dann ist das ja gut
den Link dazu findet ihr natürlich in
der Videobeschreibung
sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen ähm und
sowas sollte man gar nicht erst brauchen
15 € boah das ist aber viel was hat uns
der Weihnachtsmann
oh mein Gott
darauf freue ich mich so sehr
tattoo-stifte ich meine gut wir haben
jetzt Sicherheit Krankheit es sind alles
so sehr praktische Dinge die wir jetzt
hatten aber das ist rein fun fun
das wusste ich gar nicht das ist von der
Marke big die Feuerzeuge auch herstellen
lässt vor days okay was haben wir hier
für die ganz un kreativen gibt's hier
Schablonen und das sind die Stifte
schwarz rot und braun nicht in die Augen
oder Lippen
okay ähm mein Gott ich kann ein Tattoo
einfach ausmachen
seht ihr das
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht was ich darüber denken
soll ich habe das Gefühl auch wenn es
legal verkauft werden darf kann es doch
nicht so gesund sein ich habe mein
eigenes Natur ausgemalt habe ich
irgendwas wichtiges die nächsten Tage
nee habe ich einen Banktermin ich habe
eine Wohnung gekauft ich könnte meinen
Termin haben nein Gerichtstermin auch
nicht mehr wir malen ich glaube man muss
aufpassen die könnten schnell
austrocknen ja sie lassen sich gut
Schichten und sind so ein bisschen
klumpig aber so für ein paar süße Sachen
um sich das auf dem Festival gegenseitig
zu malen ach niemand darf sich in die
Augen machen sonst hätte ich gesagt dass
man einfach so sich ein Eyeliner malt
und wenn der für Tage bleibt es ist ja
total praktisch aber man darf wirklich
nicht in die Augen guck mal ich habe
doch hier ein Tattoo und jetzt mache ich
das extrem
Timo die haben mir fällt gerade nichts
Cooles ein ne coolen Kreuz und ein Punkt
und x lässt man sich noch so da
Tätowieren
Pfeil nach unten ich bin total cool und
tätowiert bin ich halt wirklich also sie
funktionieren erstaunlich besser als ich
erwartet habe natürlich kann man sich
noch richtig Mühe geben und wenn man
jemanden anderes anmalt dann macht es
natürlich mehr Spaß als an sich selber
umzukritzeln aber ja Tattoo Stifte fürs
Festival oder wenn ihr so flirty
unterwegs sein wollte nehmt ihr den
Stift mit und gibt dann immer eure
Handynummer auf die Körperteile der
Menschen nein
für 14 99
Eier doch okay sie lösen sich langsam
auch wenn man es nass macht das ist
schon mal ein gutes Zeichen weil es
sollte jetzt wirklich nicht zu lange
halten dürfen zwei Wochen glaube ich
immer noch damit rum ich sehe warum male
ich denn meine Hand an was ist denn los
mit mir
wenn ihr meine Adventskalender Videos
schaut dann wisst ihr ich bin leicht zu
begeistern das ist einfach so ich kann
das auch nicht abschalten wenn ihr das
nicht mögt dann ist es okay aber es ist
einfach meine Natur und jetzt freue ich
mich über ganz einfache cooling Patch
fever this Comfort pain Release gut ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob ich das bräuchte
wenn ich ein Fieber habe aber so hammer
ich habe schon gesehen wo sie das
benutzt haben und ich glaube das ist in
Japan total beliebt die kleben sie sich
das hier auf die Hauptschlagadern und
wenn das Blut da immer so durchfließt
und dass ich kalt ist dann kühlt das
halt das Blut runter und da wo kühlt es
den ganzen Körper also erzähl mir bitte
nicht dass eure Eltern euch das auf die
Stimmen geklebt haben als ihren Fieber
hatte ich glaube das gibt's noch gar
nicht so lange oder
einfach gespannt also es gibt
ja Schmerzen hat zum Beispiel dieses
kenne ich aber zu kühlen oh oh das sieht
sogar richtig schön kalt aus
aber wir tun uns jetzt einfach ich klebt
immer hier hin okay
ist das kalt und wenn ich mir das jetzt
vorstelle wenn man sich das so schön auf
den Nacken klebt wenn man im Festival da
gerade irgendwie ne wisst ihr was ich
meine es kann schon angenehm sein es ist
kalt es fühlt sich kalt an aber so fühlt
sich nicht kalt an hä ich weiß das Minze
sich kalt anfühlen kann oh doch oh die
Stelle wo es jetzt drauf war ist kälter
als die Stelle wo es nicht drauf war das
ist kalt es ist nur so komisch ich
checks nicht also es ist hier wirklich
kalt also nicht kalt das kalt Leute es
tut mir leid ich habe voll ich bin
anfangen zu drehen und die Sonne geht
immer weiter runter und es wird immer
dunkler hier ich hoffe das fällt nicht
so auf
okay switchen hier so ein bisschen von
medizinischen Produkt zu Beauty Produkt
oh mein Gott in der Hand habe merke ich
was für ein Plastik scheiße das schon
wieder ist aber ich habe eine sehr große
Familie und ich habe sehr viele Kinder
und wenn ich das zur nächsten
Geburtstagsparty mitbringe da könnt ihr
euch aber sicher sein dass ich alle sehr
freuen das sind haarclipse
auch ohne Schmetterling ich habe gemacht
das ist mein lieblingsschmetterling was
habe ich dafür bezahlt ich sag mal so
ich habe 12 Stück gekauft ich könnte
jetzt damit einladen eröffnen 16.95 guck
mal ich stelle mich einfach auf dem
Festival hin und Verkauf die für 3 € das
Stück dann habe ich 20 € Gewinn gemacht
ob mir jemand betrunken nicht dieses
Ding abkaufen würde als ich das gekauft
habe das Prinzip kennen wir dass es hier
von Konzerten und so weiter
[Gelächter]
aber man muss dafür offene Haare haben
ich verstehe es ist absoluter Müll aber
ich hätte auch nicht erwartet das ist so
kommt als ich ein kleines Mädchen war
hätte es geliebt und ich liebe es auch
fürs Festival aber so sieht es im
Dunkeln aus gar nicht schlecht ne Bam
Bam Bam Bam
guck mal seht ihr die bescheuerte da
hinten mit den zwei leuchtenden
Schmetterling das ist Vanessa genau ich
bin gespannt total cute und bestimmt
machen die mega viel Spaß auf dem
Festival und meine Kids in der Familie
werden sich freuen der große negativ
Punkt ist dass es ein einmal Produkt ist
und dass man die Batterie da nicht
austauschen kann und das finde ich sehr
sehr schade Mist wir bleiben aber beim
Thema Haare das ist wohl das Geheimnisse
Produkt auf tiktok gewesen und zwar
links Link Diamanten für die Haare ich
glaube das Prinzip ist einfach
diese blau okay
und
die kann man sich über Diamanten Haare
so Freunde Diamanten Folgen okay nächste
ist
ach komm hör doch auf das ist so cute
wir sind praktischer wenn jemand anderes
bei euch macht
hä wann hast du mal bitte zum nächsten
weiter gut es ist nicht ganz so einfach
aber wenn man einmal den Dreh raus hat
vor allem bewegen die sich auch gar
nicht
das ist jetzt mein neuer Look guck mal
muss es ein bisschen besser verteilen ne
aber ansonsten ja für so ein Festival
ist es also ich weiß es ist auch cool
auf dem Festival lässig zu wirken und
juckt mich alles nicht aber das bin halt
nicht ich bin halt einfach anders als
die anderen auch mein Gott doch das war
nur da unten haben und das klingt
so gehe ich jetzt jeden Tag raus was
kostet der Bling Bling machen für die
Haare 10.99 ja da macht man nichts
falsch mit dafür sind Kindergeburtstag
wenn die Kinder sich dann so glitzern
machen wollen ist auch cool und 4,3
Sterne will ich auch sagen es ist
irgendwie auf den ersten Blick wirkt wie
so ein Schrott Produkt aber es
funktioniert einwandfrei und das
Ergebnis ist echt toll man sollte sich
nur bei der Anordnung ein bisschen mehr
Mühe geben aber ansonsten sehen
es ist so kalt ich habe hier aber kein
allergischen Schock gekriegt und ich
könnte das sogar wieder verwenden ich
meine das ist jetzt da drauf ich weiß
nicht wie lange das noch hält aber man
kann es umkleben und jetzt sind wir auch
schon bei der letzten Kategorie das
Festival Outfit und da habe ich mir
wirklich sehr viele Gedanken gemacht was
wäre das perfekte Festival Outfit
natürlich kann man cute hübsch Bund
leuchtend aussehen aber ich muss auch
praktisch sein und da habe ich mir ein
Outfit überlegt okay
jetzt Cover ich habe mir eine bessere
geholt mit vielen Taschen da könnt ihr
nichts sagen das ist praktisch
dann warte
die ein bisschen eng ist die auch
Taschen hat
richtig cool so ich habe jetzt mein
Handy was in keine dieser Taschen passt
cool oh man na gut auf jeden Fall habe
ich hier eine Tasche für irgendwas dann
hier noch eine Tasche und auf der
anderen Seite noch mal das gleiche
schnuderig aus
diesen diesen auf keinen Fall aber Leute
viel Taschen sind zu wenig wir brauchen
noch eine Hose mit Taschen ja gut wir
sind noch zwei Taschen und hier so eine
Tasche
ja jetzt kommt das hier noch wirklich
zum eins mein Festival Outfit ist jetzt
einfach ein Festival Mitarbeiter Outfit
geworden ja wir brauchen hier hier
machen Leute Krawall und Remmidemmi ja
weil ich könnte das auch auf der Bühne
aber wir brauchen Verstärkung wenn ich
so rumlaufen würde würde mich nicht
wundern wenn mich jemand anspricht um
ihm zu helfen aber ist okay ich bin da
um zu helfen ich glaube es nicht ich
habe hier sogar so ein Haken kann ich
mein Handy daran machen das wäre so
lustig ja ich bin gerade auf dem Fest
Story oh mein Gott und dann bisher habe
die Fan spielt weiter uh ich habe mein
Handy nicht fallen lassen
okay leute das ist wirklich spät draußen
es ist 20:10 Uhr es ist Zeit zum
Schlafengehen Leute ich hoffe ihr hattet
viel Spaß beim zuschauen wenn dem so ist
dann gib dem Video gerne einen Daumen
hoch und schreibt eine Kommentar das
hilft mir ganz deutlich Algorithmus
pusht also wir sehen uns dann ne ich bin
auf dem Deichmann Festival interessiert
uns da sehen ähm sprechen bitte an und
machen Foto mit mir das pusht mein Ego
immer fantastisch gut und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Mal wieder bis dann
tschüss
[Musik]
malwanne